There are 10 commitments
to change the history of Galicia,
10 great action facts to boost
the greater transformation
and the greatest advance of Galicia in 40 years.
They are aware that it is not going to be easy.
My feeling is strong,
with experience
and with great enthusiasm to take on the challenges.
I also feel that there is 1 collective waste
to start 1 new stage.
Be it vitality,
friendship,
of confidence,
of collective enthusiasm
around the Great Common Cause
because of hailstorm,
because of welfare,
the prosperity of edofuturo 2 galegos edas galegas.
This is how I understand politics
as 1 powerful instrument
to improve life,
people,
to combat inequalities.
Eh create 1 larger world
policy is 1 instrument we have
to build the galiza we love and dream of,
to make 1 to Galicia a reality in large,
1 living,
country,
modern,
productive,
Yes.
It's fair
to galiza that we love and deserve
and that we keep
to be able to start up as of odazaoito in february
or to trust
the Galicians and the Galicians